okay so for people who are watching this
live stream this is one of an infinite
series of meetings adding polish to the
Wolfram language with lots of looking at
specific functions that might be
incrementally put into the system so
let's get started all right well so for
millions of years we've had this
function called bool that Wow there
initialization cells in here it's
interesting okay
that does that so the question is do we
want something that goes back from one
and zero and turns them into true and
false I think we imagine doing this
right when we invented bool long long
ago but for some reason we never
actually implements it I mean we're
going to call it into a spool basically
anybody want to comment on that what
would he do other numbers that is a good
question um 50 shades of true no I I
think the obvious thing to do is to do
what it does I mean what does bool do if
you give it something other than true
and false
okay just stays on evaluated in that
case I would think it would turn into
true for any other number now I what
should it do if you go at 1.7 which what
should he do it if you give it machine 0
I would say any kind of zero is false
any other number is true
and I would I would think that anything
else is remains are evaluated right yeah
maybe it could be extended to until East
goes to true I'm Justin goes to true I'm
sorry water what which Universal yeah of
what
until East likely yeah what would that -
I think it's gotta be listable I would
have knowest alright let's look at um so
the other case of this is the enum case
where you're basically taking an
indicator function that is taking saying
you know I don't know this is a bad name
for it but um something where you say -
and then the enumeration is a B and C
but this is kind of a stupid function
because that is really you know that
list sub - basically now the only the
only thing is so that would give B no
that's the inverse e now my guests right
and so the other
case is the enum analog which would be
something like B comma ABC making sense
then that would give two and what's the
relation with blue one idea I mean bool
is going from the true/false from
true/false to an integer right this is
going
I mean arguably you know you could do
something where by default if you ask
for something that isn't in the list it
would give zero right I mean the
alternative way to do that which might
be a little bit weirder and perhaps a
bad idea it's a second argument to bool
but
is that bull acts on bullying why is the
num a nerdy version of that well I mean
the point would be that the default bull
would be yeah so just thinking affirming
make you over generalizing bull to a
characteristic functions later to which
to a collect a stick function something
that yes that's right I mean it it is
this is like characteristic function I
mean this would be something like you
know that would be what bool would be
that will be the full form in this
concept well that says here's the list
of truths this is the no it's false it's
you know it should give zero I don't
think the champions of this particular
thing are in this meeting I mean I think
that the statement was has come up a
bunch of times and things like image
processing um where you're saying you
know given this list I mean clearly this
is fairly easy to do with part right so
I'm still thinking about inverse boo
what we proposed is basically possible
0q week it also has the question of what
do we do with some sort of throaty and
zero that very complicated and not
obviously zero it's hopeless
I mean you know in words it's looking
since structurally is the thing a number
mm-hmm no okay so the question then that
will come up is what about inverse pool
of you know PI squared should it
numerous eyes it to determine the answer
was
we do have a complicated numeric
expression which is actually zero you
apply a full simplified but it will take
some time to realize that no I know I'm
saying punt in those cases I'm saying if
it's not an explicit structural number
don't try just to return an evaluate it
I mean let me point out if you did
return on evaluated and then you hit it
with n you'll awful simplify or whatever
that will resolve it
right okay so look none of the champions
of this enum thing here so I think um we
should not figure out what to do with
enum right now but the inverse pool
things seems straightforward we have
planned to do it when we introduce bool
originally let me just I'm just curious
I'm just gonna search my archive for the
inverse pool business just because I
seem to remember that term
[Music]
but that was a discussion let's just see
whether we had anything else to say
about it um see how many years ago this
this was happening
huh
well inverse ball came up in 1997
to do list
[Music]
this was our just to entertain ourselves
I suppose this was our to do list in
1997
[Music]
which of these have we now done we have
done lets convolve we've done that yeah
interesting
we've got divides qm we've got substring
q so the only one from 1997 that we
don't have is in verse pool let me just
see whether there's any further
discussion that was of interest
subsequent to that
um
we seem to have had a whole bunch
discussion in when did bull limit when a
bull come in yeah right so this is some
this is further discussion 1998 of
inverse pool
[Music]
and it seems like 2008 we had a whole
bunch of discussion a short name for the
inverse of bool okay so we had a
discussion about this okay
that's amusing we had a discussion here
in which some just to show you this one
um in which the possible 0 Q this exact
same discussion came up it would have
been worse if it was if it was you who
brought it up as opposed to breath and
Bhuvan - um okay well look it seems like
inverse bool is a perfectly reasonable
thing to have we just didn't have it
before because we never got around to it
I think now we've we've got reason to
have it um we were asking extensively
here for a short name for the another
possible name
oh for goodness sake that's some
ah somebody had suggested Spock as a
name for inverse bool great
um very funny
Danny you you mean who suggested that
yeah suggestion that's Pleasant a
oh I think it was
joke it might even even been initiated
by me it looks like my bad sense of
humor here
um okay anyway there were no serious
other suggestions Oh ideas were unborn D
boo this is some these are these are
very non serious suggestions I mean
these were unbelievable
Aristotle not a serious suggestion
[Music]
logical
could we get some whoever's got
background noise contribute your cell
phone yet um
you
I think in verse pool is the least crazy
of these comments on other people I was
trying to find
think related to zero because what we
are doing here is some sort of X it's
not explicit 0 Q because it's not a q
function but we this is a function that
targets 0 explicitly well you can think
of it that way I mean I see what you're
saying this is a function I mean the
question is should you think of it as
you know going to asking a question
about an integer or should you think of
it as essentially a type conversion okay
someone is suggesting on sander is
suggesting a Lube which is funny but not
useful for inverse bool okay gosh can we
see any other better name d bool
I think D bool is much more obscure even
than inverse ball any other thoughts
here Rumble that's not crazy that's not
crazy might be better than inverse ball
inverse Bulls suggest something
mathematical in 1 to 1 and so on this is
almost
which is basically the opposite look the
whole point is Bulls George Bulls big
contribution was to say that what had
been called true and false could be
viewed as zero one and what we're doing
here is we're saying okay answer the
question I mean maybe this should have
something more like come up to boolean
it's really more to true/false no no no
that's confusing things even more
because we're saying bool the
contribution of okay George Boole his
contribution was you know Aristotle and
friends that had true and false Poole
said no you can view those as one and
zero right now boolean in programming
languages has come to mean something
that has these two possible values which
represent true and false but in
programming languages end up being often
written as zero m1 that makes sense so
it's very confused there so I think
boolean is a hopeless way to go yes this
will be a function that returns true or
false but it's not a queue function so
I'm trying to align it with some other
function that has that property right
but we have to have a way of thinking
about you know we've got to have a way
of
this in terms of look I mean clearly
this thing is basically non zero q yes
in fact someone pointed out on the
livestream it's basically just the
function positive that's true I mean
this is one of these cases where well
it's sort of true except that we in this
particular case it's anything other than
zero what is the relationship between
this and Kronecker Delta that I guess
chronica Delta has two arguments right
yeah I think it's gonna have any number
okay you mean including one yes but then
I bet it's always gonna give one no what
does it do here I think it's either way
if you could see what I see I see I see
okay fair enough okay so this I mean
this is closer to two true false okay
the question is you sing a piece of code
and that piece of code says you know
list here and it says something like
let's say it says pick you know ABC and
then you see a piece of code that says
something like that
mm-hmm I have to say I think that's that
too true/false is less obscure than
saying inverse bool or from bool what's
a bit long but how about logical value
I think that okay you know the thing is
that it's mapping from this hack which
is the boolean hack
I mean that's what it really is no it
isn't even integer number two logic um I
mean this might suggest that is a
structural to true/false thing as
opposed to a computational to true/false
thing logical values sounds doesn't that
sound a bit too general
and now you also agree on insisting not
having this function very related to the
maths because the problem of funding
whether something is a seed or noise is
very hard right well it's allowed to
come back and evaluate it I would hope
sure which is what happening to
true/false doesn't suggest that it could
come back on evaluated right I'm not
sure
we'll have a queue so it's like Hugh
would tell us that I would find some
sweet Ora you know I had thought of
truth-value had just kind of didn't like
it because there's no false in the
truth-value okay so what would the
definition of truth value is some
it's okay I'm not against it um well is
it does it mean the right thing what is
the truth value does the truth value you
know it's a truth value something that
one can reasonably say is some let's
look at it it has the same problem as
logical value which is that it sort of
implies you're working in in something
like I mean in a total a typical version
of this like you know our friendly
Wikipedia blows itself up on line one on
the Ciccio right what it says is with
truth values R 1 or T so that's already
blown up the idea that truth value means
unfortunately the word value is is
already you know a problem there hmm of
course this might also be the the reason
that we didn't do this before is because
we weren't sure about the name yeah well
the the sander on the live stream is
saying to ball would have been nice if
the other was called from boo but the
whole point is that we're using the fact
that the the we're using this piece of
history that maybe nobody knows about
what boule actually did um I have to say
the one that I'm least unhappy about
will be - true false
it has the advantage of being very clear
terms of what it does I'm not sure that
it is in any way I mean what we could do
is we could say to true/false and then
we could say that its second arguments
if it has a second argument would give
potentially the list of truths
now I don't know that's the right thing
to do I mean it something would give the
mapping that the problem is the mapping
is a 0 origin mapping with a 0 there
which is kind of a mess for us I think
we should go ahead and implement thus
under the name to true false it's a
little weird though because you know
bool is the inverse of to true false
which is kind of weird all right what do
we have as their as the top candidates
we have from bool which has the
advantage that it goes nicely with bool
okay so let's say you see in your code
you know no there I wrote it out pick
ABC from bool it's a little weird
because people think of boolean z' you
know that's the problem with this sort
of abuse of the term boolean okay what
what people think here of the things
suggested I prefer to true/false so far
because it puts the emphasis on
true/false it it removes the emphasis
from checking that something is zero
okay you prefer it to from bool what
does he think people are already very
confused about - yes I think yes it
seems to suggest that it takes a boolean
that's that's what the first thing I
ever drink yeah I'm with hmm okay
Sandra's asking is it from o2 bool well
the problem is yeah yeah right
I mean this is the confusion because
bool you know the George Boole in his
book laws of thought in whatever 18 mm
30 something 30-something 40 something
anyway
around that time you know his big point
was you can do Aristotelian type logic
using ones and zeros that was the point
that was why now that subsequently got
utterly abused when people started
talking about Bulli anne's all right so
listen I think the tentative conclusion
is to true/false do we agree let's go
ahead with that and then we'll look at
it again when we've got implementation
and documentation fair okay all right
let's go on to the next item
yes yeah so this is something we have
discussed before and we have added here
two sections from your notes from two
files curry of three and cargo four and
then something I wrote long ago before
Christmas when we were working on curry
okay this is just to recollect ideas and
see whether you are still interest
well so the issue here is can we make a
pattern that represents a nested and
arbitrarily nested collection of
functions and the the next question is
why do we care I mean we've been able to
get away without this for thirty years
why do we care
um and I think the answer that was there
were things that were involved with
Tony's work where it seemed to be
important um and this certainly
something so so what
let's see head gap so the idea is once
we we were discussing curry we thought
that perhaps it was important to have a
variety of function supporting their
multiple burrows pair of brackets and
nesting so these are two different
things but both might be important
oh boy so this is more about multiple
brackets rather than nesting at the same
problem up here well I don't think that
the head is the right to brand so to
speak for this I mean if there is a
brand it's gonna be a curry type brand
yes your notes are further down we
discussed things like some value head
curry the main conclusion we got last
time was something called curry see
goats okay but I think this is more for
multiple pairs of brackets who rather
than nested heads
okay fine but that's a different thing
so this case here is the curry sequence
case well that's a case where this thing
can represent not just a single argument
to f of X but an arbitrary sequence of
arguments def of X so in particular it
can match
what the heck well that that's not a
complete thing there this is saying what
is the same I don't understand this is
that supposed to match okay okay I see I
see so this matches that form there so
in other words curry sequence is a match
oh that doesn't care about the
bracketing it only cares about the
sequence right but how does it even know
what the bracketing is well we would
have to implement this it's not easy to
implement but currently curry is able to
ignore the brackets the structural
brackets discount it just counts
arguments okay so what are the issues
that we don't have one of the functions
we don't have um it's something that
takes that and turns it into something
like I'm not sure what the right way of
doing it is but something like you know
no actually that's wrong I mean but some
something maybe where they're sub lists
here where it it is you know curry
sequence to list so to speak we don't
have any what is the easiest way to do
that every you
recursively with patterns go ahead what
we just had
folding head basically or something yeah
I mean I keep on not thinking of this as
a head really I mean it is the case that
this is a composite head but I keep on
thinking of it as going the other way
and adding tacking on arguments in a
curried form making sense I mean this in
fact is a you know so let's see so I
mean this operation we don't have a good
way to do this right now on the other
hand we haven't exactly missed it in a
very long time what is other than
completeness what is driving our desire
to put this kind of thing in nothing in
particular it is where we were working
with curry we thought that maybe it
might be interesting to have these
things but they are not very important
same thing happens with the nesting of
heads it's something that might be
useful in some cases but it's not
alright so let's let's not worry about
this right now
let's keep it our list and let's not
worry about it for right now I think
might be a good topic for summer school
that's a good topic if somebody can note
that it's a good topic for we sometimes
do some lectures on design that might be
a good topic for that all right let's
move on apply thread okay that is the
famous thing that what what is this
doing here that's is that the thing that
combines Association oh that's a
different thing what is this
so disability comes from another of your
meetings and this one's from database
integration meeting yeah I think the
last line is their clearest
you
you
yes and do we like that name
well to me this is this is not our apply
is more like instruct this is a
threading we can you seek us build this
using map thread and construct
okay so construct we do that so what are
you climbing that this is some kind of
threat construct construct thread yes or
in here for example you can do inner
construct a little lists
yes and then yes it lists and then and
then you need a comma list right right
what would be the convention here of
whether this is so in the case of thread
what that will be doing is it will be
taking if we said thread G of that right
it does this
so in a sense this is thread construct
is that right yes I think so is that
obscure is that a reasonable name and by
the way given that name right then this
should go oh yeah that's right those are
two corresponding associations just
thread it to work on associations I
don't know
you
that does not work try comma Comanche I
don't know
sometimes with thread you have to
specify which hit another have some
sociation calm association what is the
association thread but that's that's
like map thread it takes ham no sir no
you're right that does a different thing
that's taking a list of values in the
list of key and create an association
okay so the question is why does thread
not work with associations now clearly
it's a little tricky because it's a
question of reordering in the
associations and so on
I think we should raise that question
who who would know about that what if I
know about that perhaps I think this is
wisdom for probably Constantin okay fine
let's ask him I sort of vaguely remember
that thread was on the list of functions
to support Association maybe it was it
was simply down prioritized or maybe
there was some problem with it
okay so thread thread construct was a
pretty weird name yeah in my opinion
it's very easy to construct it with
inner as we did always map thread I'm
not fully sure it's in any of these
function well I think that there are a
lot of cases in this database thing
where in this case for example I think
the inner case is extremely obscure um
you know if I might
so Sushma I think process wise the fact
that people who initiate these functions
aren't in this meeting is kind of
unfortunate you suggested this function
[Music]
but this came out of a discussion from
from yes right I think they had this
function but it was okay I think we have
to ask them again I I think it's a
particularly in this case here well a
question is is there a three argument
form of this function for example when
by the way I don't really support
necessarily that it's thread because it
doesn't really give it's just giving the
naked lists here it's not actually
giving I mean thread usually has it's
more like map thread right because what
it's doing is it's just taking the
it's not taking three of those lists and
then threading three through it yes yes
I mean the notation in map thread is
much better than the notation thread
like become follow month right
I believe it yeah but the problem is map
thread
I understand but map thread okay we can
do the same thing mad Fred construct
coma the list of public lists VI I agree
that would work you need a list of the
two lists yeah that works fine well
let's push this back to the database
integration folk and let's sum two
things here we should make sure there
are examples in construct a map thread
that show that case there and let's push
back to the database folk and just say
use map thread construct example
something nice here is that if you add a
third list then we can construct
functions of multiple arguments very
easily which is nice yes
all right fine okay so for the time
being we don't need this function okay
should we go on okay yes so this is the
discussion of a function we have named
the multiple ways I'm still calling it
nest threat but yes so the name is not
clear because it's related to multiple
other operations hobby what we were just
discussing somebody is asking on the
livestream what is the inverse of
construct what is the inverse of
construct the thing that takes that and
turns of the list F XY
prettislim living very easy its goes to
true yeah yeah but that's only gonna
work in this case that's not gonna do
that in general to do that in general if
I had x squared there that's so the
question is how do you go from a head
and arguments to a straight list then
then it's little one I see so you're
claiming is that it's just level of f of
XY
[Music]
comma 1 comma heads to true yeah yeah I
think that's correct
alright it seems to be the answer by the
way we might put that also in the
construct documentation under properties
and relations so
is there is a discussion of the name the
syntax is some implementation which you
already executed and examples to play
with okay what is the cigar so this is
the idea that we have an array and many
lists of keys and we want to construct a
nested Association oh yeah right
so this has come through multiple names
exactly yes and I think that the main
thing here is that it depends where we
want to use it if this is only going to
be related to rules and Association then
probably we need a name which sounds
very key Association like and if it's
generalized as I did there to a more
powerful function that is able to work
in other contexts then I suggest some
other name like this next thread but I'm
not very happy with nest right sounds
awfully obscure what what does it do
again okay so you're saying so it's a D
of the same operation here that you see
there with those data sets but
generalizing rule and Association to our
other heads like we generalized the F
and G functions in other in other places
distribute in our set
some on the livestream suggests that
this operation be called deconstruct
it's kind of interesting I don't know if
it's terribly useful but it's kind of
interesting
you
I mean the problem is the you know the
fact that heads and their arguments are
distinguished in some way I mean in you
know the world of Lisp or something that
was not traditionally done um but in our
um you know it has turned out over the
last thirty years to be very valuable to
distinguish the head from arguments this
is kind of saying hey that's a cute name
though it's very cute name
okay to be saved away
I don't think we need this right now can
um okay let's but let's go back to what
we're talking about here so what you've
implemented this under nest threat is
that right yes
I'm telling what it does again so there
are if you run these key the examples at
the beginning of this section I have
disc I have an example of level two and
an example of level three
okay but let me be not so obscure let's
start off with level one okay so it
takes a usually other function I also
have there which is called key
distribute which is singular key
distribute takes okay yeah key
distribute takes the keys and the array
okay I need to type something in here
key distribute takes keys let's say ABC
it's a list of lists so it has quite a
list of lists the F camisa can be easily
generalized it doesn't work but it had
two lists in the first one
okay so now let me understand this so
those are keys the first thing is I all
right I remember this okay so that the
first thing is a list of keys and the
second thing so if I make this
multi-dimensional by having a list of
keys and then another list of keys there
might yes now you need no you need a
three by two array innocent argument
okay this is the thing that is
essentially painting key labels over an
object right yep umm yes this is a
useful thing why is that wrong because
the other way around
I'm making this edge exactly it said to
us right exactly
so let me understand that structurally
so if I if I take this that's so kind of
obscure right because this this case
okay so this is the sort of the template
for the structure in saying that level
one it's got three things which are
going to be labeled like that level two
it's got those things right yeah and so
okay so that's what Kiedis region so
what is your nest threat doing yes so
now copy that input change their name
I took nest threat and now write F
before a pass first argument and G as
last argument iiiii so it's the same
thing London snarling creature yeah
exactly
um and why do you think I mean in order
to do that what you just showed
do you think it's useful to generalize
it that way but for example sometimes do
you want rules but want lists nested
lists not associations registers would
write G his list instead of Association
yes I mean that's useful one for example
the repeated keys right
but win it in this case you're giving
the key pattern and so unless you stick
in a repeated key you're not going to
get a repeated key exactly but it may be
that for some reason do you need I mean
because they are dates or something and
something happens happened twice in a
day why would they be dates I don't
understand that given that they're
nested a nested structure like that well
it may be that you are actually I can
give you an example X wire days of the
week maybe see a month's you could
easily have no that would be no no
that's that's not an example in fact um
I mean that's a pretty obscure thing
that's happening here I mean in ER isn't
your average least obscure function
either I mean I tend to think are we
nice to have a name where the default
operation is this but where there's sort
of an escape valve maybe just a third
argument or something which can give the
explicit functions to use
distribute in which because we put the F
and G functions at the end you are not
forced to write them right like you are
in in mod or Maps right Exeter right
okay well okay so the main issue here I
think that makes more sense to put them
at the end but the main question then is
okay I mean this is sort of an array
labeling exercise yes I mean that's not
the right name but um didn't we have a
name like array key or something we had
names related to real labeling which I
didn't like no sense and I mean honestly
label isn't the right concept here
anyway well it sort of is because the
main place is going to be associations
or possibly rules mm-hmm then I think it
key would be nicer than legal okay
key distribute just is absolutely
incomprehensible for what it's doing I
mean it's it's really put keys into an
array let's think I was trying to
connections to other functions and then
does not work there's a connection to
distribute and I want to map in text
it's not the map index that's really
obscure so well
the difference with map indexed is that
map indexed is going to insert the full
party specification well here we are
inserting there the key at that level
and not the sequence of or the list of
keys that leads to that point right I
see map index so your point is that it's
inserting that map indexed just looks at
yeah I mean that's another case that you
could do here except for what you're
doing here this is a case where you're
telling it what indices to use whereas
here you're just taking me
naturally-occurring indices so to speak
and you know putting them into the
function that you're applying okay so
boy there are so many bad names that
immediately come to mind about index
array and so on which could which
immediately means completely the wrong
thing okay so what how do we think about
this this is taking a it's an array but
we want to put I mean it's sort of I
mean there are ugly composite names like
I mean that's an
category of totally incomprehensible but
it has at least a soup of words that
give you some chance um what are some
other array type names that we have from
I mean we've got things like array
reshape and so on which feels somewhat
similar to this well but this is more
than reshaping it it's changing the type
because we are returning an association
so a possible name could be also a Bri
Association but I'm worried that these
are two really really big players yeah I
agree
I think that's obscure I think that's
the name we had at one point for this
yeah um right so this is not a totally
you know unrelated function because this
is giving you this is telling you well
this isn't restructuring the array here
like the dimensions are kept and what is
it related to distribute can you go a
bit up in their notebook on the right
yes so here yes so here you see this
last example in which I'm replacing F
and G by a time some plus and suddenly
we have a linear combination you see
that the one you are now pointing with
your mm-hmm with your cursor and so that
operation that looks very much like like
distributing
if women if if F and G at times and plus
right because those are the defaults for
this ticket now I understand right so
you're claiming that this operation here
it's like times and plot what yes if F
and G are in many places functions with
default times on Plus respectively and
and yes so we are always having F when
we have times as the main function like
okay well a few in terms of
algebraically here the yes it's
multiplying the the elements of the
first array of the first object with the
second object yeah and then and then
filing the whole thing it's multiplying
at level 1 by X ABC and multiplying at
level 2 by X Y it's not adding
everything yes but that's not what this
tribute does right distribute takes
what does distribute do
you
what is this tribute to a multiple level
so this is f G a B no distribute doesn't
have a form of multiple levels in a
sense in the same way that we have
thread a mud thread there is distribute
and this other thing that could have
been separated into the functions and
the erase and then it will look closer
to this function I'm suggesting here
so distribute is very close to fry
in the sense that it requires an
expression which already contains the
heads inside and then mud thread was
created severity but we'll have a map
distribute
distribute - it will be a bit what we
are doing here because because in that
case map is actually putting you know
the function on to each of these whereas
here we're doing an association play so
to speak instead of the function right I
mean this could be we could imagine our
mystery thing here let's just take a
simple case of it but if we said list
list FG list list XY could turn that
into f of X G of Y right that will be
the map e thing to do
right as opposed to what we're actually
doing here which is to make those
association elements right
whoops makes sense right so I mean this
would be I don't even know how you do
that
in that would I see the relationship
between this and what you're saying is
it's like a distribute relationship
because what you're doing is you're
saying the that that really is a rule F
goes to X and then the whole thing is
wrapped in an association relevant list
yes something like that I cannot claim I
fully understand the reason I will try
to to suggest well to construct this so
I mean what this is saying is that this
thing here is being inserted those
arguments are being inserted as keys in
an association as opposed to those
arguments being inserted as heads like
in this case here
you
um I guess it in distribute we have
their ace the coefficient separated from
the excavation see in the first example
in the distributed page and and it feels
similar to I have the keys separated
from the array and I distribute them and
I have them all no I agree
I agree but but look look at the case
that I'm talking about here in this case
the functions are being used as heads in
this case they're being used as
essentially labels yes but we have Keene
the name so I think it's well I
understand that if if we have key in the
name Frank
you
I mean you know the only name here that
is even vaguely making it for me is a
Reiki distribute
you
mm-hmm well one thing is clear we can
certainly implement this function well
your very question is if it is a Reiki
distribute then what we've got is
essentially the labels the array and
then potentially we have F and G yes
what I've added as well you can try is a
level spec so you specify don't want to
go where I'm comforted so let's see if I
have an example if you go back to Isis I
mean for example if label labels had
lists if some of the labels were lists
you have to specify that
right I mean in other words if F and G
were lists they could represent another
level down in the actual sort of
burrowing through the array well they
could merely be that you want the label
of something at level two to be XYZ or
something yes you have an example a bit
above in internetwork okay if you screw
up it that data said they're not you see
it's it's still keeping lists at level
three it just it just inserted
and that's why there's a tool in the
pastures are going
you
what happens what about lists in the
keys argument I say the Leafs of the
keys argument I see I see I see I see
they've got to correspond so that means
that you go down to level two in both
the keys on the array exactly yeah and
you keep the values if they're if the
values are still that level you keep the
lists exactly
so are you proposing that that occur
before the F and G what do we have a
precedent for that we do I think so for
something what do we have that what's
that for
something has a level spec precedent I
think here could be I think it's more
important in the FG outer is a fairer is
a horrifying verilux function yes
perhaps level itself boy these are all
functions and I was in love version one
sorry which one level yes level is able
to go down yeah okay so that does
something a little bit like this it
takes a level spec and then it has a
function that can be applied who five
argument function a perhaps this the
first three mmm
enough render and then we see whether
they need appears for the others by the
way somebody is asking and I think this
calls for a small demo of whether there
is a chat functionality yes and version
11.3 there is chat and we should be
using it for these meetings and I'm even
going to say I could add some of you to
this the next time we should use this
chat this we've been saying we're going
to do this for these livestream things
to provide people the possibility of
joining our our chat session which would
then allow all sorts of war from
language expressions to be just sent
back and forth um okay but back to this
for a moment and then we need to wrap up
unfortunately look I think array he
distributed it's a horrifying name but I
think it's the least bad we've had
okay
kind of a horrifying thing so I mean the
the the official version of this would
be F is what rule who yesterday is
Association yes
who's it to them GF like distribute so
would be Association followed by rule
yes to follow distribute itself okay and
those are the defaults you have to write
them no I understand that but so if I
wanted to do the other case I would do
list and construct that would give me
the map case for example hmm okay
gosh this is so obscure because the fact
is people are gonna use this to label
rows and columns that's what it's
practice gonna get used for an array key
distribute is one of the more obscure
things you could call essentially
something which is conceptually labeling
rows and columns okay so what it's doing
is you know at some level it's turning
lists into associations which is how we
ended up with array association which
again as you say is I think too it's too
big for this functionality presumably
yes isn't
how common do we think this is going to
be what's the inverse of this operation
it's some sort of more delivering venues
yeah which we don't have it's the first
I know value is right now I doesn't even
have a second argument I suspect
you
and Trustin so it's listable
I mean this is I mean the other version
of this is sort of like I mean this is
really a ray to association but
now how do we what is the other version
there's an association thread which is
trying to do something like this as well
right
yes at one level that's another thing we
discuss the possibility of generalizing
this function to do what we are
suggesting but we thought that the
multi-level nature didn't fit what about
the following possibility I mean what
we've got here I see I so we've got a
two argument form of this that has the
keys and values separated like that
that's unfortunate well of course
Association thread might want to use
keys which are lists the exhausts
exactly exactly so we can't do that
without saying I mean the default for
Association thread can't be to do this
we would have to give Association thread
a second or third argument yes
specifying at which level we have the
keys or require that users insert key so
that we are sure these are keys why is
that going to work to insert key
explicitly I mean in other words I think
that's I think you want the other way
around right because you've got to be
able to take look if we take something
which is like let's take our example
here okay you got that thing and that
would be an association thread so let's
see what it would look like it's
Association thread of that either the
thing itself okay so there we go
you know so sister is not completely
crazy for this it's really not
completely crazy because as you point
out we're gonna have to have a a level
spec anyway in the saraiki distribute
thing yes but thread and is a different
operation it takes itself and level spec
and it uses it differently and what we
want what is it - it goes down in both a
race in this soullessness well but the
first argument of what we want over what
we are suggesting is not really an array
into which you go deeper the depth is
represented in the argument number I
suicide so these X Y could be lists but
the fact is the top level
and now I'm completely confused I think
you're wrong but there needs to be a
level spec right because I mean the case
where this is has lists here would look
like this yes but that's fine what I'm
saying is that those x1y1 are the keys
of the second level not because they are
at level two in that array it's because
they are in the second position of that
list I agree but what I'm saying is why
do we need a level specification because
other than I mean then just if you don't
want the level if you don't want all the
levels to a take on this list
yes but what I'm saying is that for for
what we want we need a matrix in the
first argument an association thread who
wants only a list so we have this this
way what we need I understand what we
need is one more level of encrusting an
association thread yes well okay
I see otherwise association thread can't
know
between a list of
uh keys that are supposed to be lists
and this structuring thing
you
so the reason we talked about array real
Abel is by analogy with array reshape
although the argument order is opposite
sona's asking is it is it a bad story of
SH is asking is it bad to have a couple
of built-in synonyms for the same
function yes it's a it's a we've we've
never done that we've never had to do
that and honestly to utterly obscure
synonyms won't help us um
you
let me see okay okay but by the way I
mean this level of thinking I think we
had gotten part of the way there before
we we kind of need to finish this right
now I'm late for something else but but
Tim okay so I understand
you
okay so right now we have that first dog
what are some other examples where we
have key you know key functions that do
something with keys like that
I have the impression that the general
theme here is that the association
functions are very one-dimensional
well here is one of the first cases in
which we want to handle associations at
a multi level that's why we are funding
new ideas yes well but that's why we
have ok that's why the array word is
coming in there
is distribute the right concept today
we've got a key but what are we really
doing with it it's one connection
threading distributing a map indexing
are things that seem similar
um what about array distribute
I was that completely crazy
well given the first argument and keys
well there are only keys if it turn into
an association I mean it's very bad if
it's it's a if everything is key key
like and then we find out that the
escape valve case with different FS and
G's is common I think perhaps we need
two functions one which is very key
oriented and his inner locus hmm
let's just talk about for a second about
array distribute mm-hmm and what would
it say it would say distributes the keys
what would it say it would say creates
nested that's kind of weird
creates a nested Association
by distributing the sequences of keys
blah blah blah over the array blah blah
blah over successive levels in the array
blah blah blah click that description is
okay creates a nested Association
what else would array distributed mean
you
you
what is there a meaningful name
I mean Association distributors seems
kind of crazy is that crazy
well there is an obligation of having an
association in input hmm so array seems
you
you
why don't we go ahead and implement this
under the name of ray distribute which
we may yet regret um and then discuss it
again or is it implemented already I
have some small prototype you can look
at the code there in the notebook I
don't want to UM it's question does the
code have any weirdness in it I mean is
that is the code telling us that
something is crazy in some way no no
it's a combination of an estimate thread
let's the origin of calling this nest
flight origin nest trellis
obscure I mean I agree it is that I was
just letting the cold suggestin yes fine
see people are gonna think about this as
labeling I could imagine this not being
told what do you think about this you
think this is too general
no it's finite I'm a nice key a bit
because I think key is if fundamentally
I mean it's it's even in what you wrote
sequences of keys but yeah but remember
then the other cases you know array
distribute okay so do we need the level
I claim we don't need the level spec
I don't think we need the levels back
yeah and then we need the outer and the
inner functions right right um and this
would be
by oh I see
creates a nested this is basically a
nested outer f by distributing sequences
of distributed
oh my gosh the function it's basically
by distributing inner half of hash one
well I have to comment for the
documentation one is that we can still
have what you had before which was clear
and then say in different lines oh yeah
yeah I understand replaces Association
by whatever I was trying to see whether
there was a better
I wonder what we do for distribute maybe
for distribute we just do that because
it may be anything else is too obscure
we can also explain it like map for it
does which is with the actual formula we
are right all right I think I have to
go to the next thing here um let's
implement it as
they distribute and let's see if we can
write documentation under that name okay
um and great okay thanks to everybody on
the livestream
um and talk to you all soon